thank you thank you dr sherwood randall
for joining us we appreciate you taking
the time out of a very busy
uh week for you and we look forward to
welcoming you into the briefing room
uh we're next available thank you it was
a pleasure to be with you thank you
bye-bye do i have a few just more
additional updates uh supervise
all of you and then we will take as many
questions as we can in the time allotted
first uh the federal government is also
monitoring the weather's impacts on our
vaccination efforts
we are experiencing delays in cobit 19
vaccine shipments and deliveries
cdc and federal partners are working
closely with the jurisdictions as well
as manufacturing and shipping partners
to assess weather conditions and to help
mitigate potential delivery days and
delays and cancellations our coveted
response team is in constant
communication with local officials
hearing about what's going on on the
ground by doing so we're able to work to
deploy the resources of federal
government to the extent we can to
address issues related to deliveries
distribution and vaccinations
this week we've already had and will
continue to field
many one-on-one calls correspond the
email and conduct new meetings with
states tribes territories and key
partners
to remain in close contact about our
vaccination efforts and the impact of
the storm
we're also working with our partners to
move up scheduled deliveries whenever
possible
and to surge shipment operations through
the end of the week into the weekend
we're in conversation about extended
hours and additional appointments to try
and reschedule shots given the storm
our goal is to ensure vaccine
distribution across all jurisdictions is
as stable
and equitable as possible through this
program and we continue to monitor
work closely with jurisdictions and
pharmacy partners to achieve that goal
and that i would expect tomorrow that
when you all have your
one of the three uh weekly uh updates
from the cova team they will provide a
more extensive update
on this and also answer any questions
you have about the work
uh that they have been focused on second
is today
president biden's immigration bill the
u.s citizenship act will be formally
introduced in congress
this legislation modernizes our
immigration system
it provides hard-working people who have
enriched our communities and lived here
for decades
to earn citizenship the president's
priorities reflected in this bill
are to responsibly manage the border
keep families together
grow our economy address the root causes
of migration from central america
and ensure that america remains a refuge
for those fleeing persecution
the president believes all of these
require immediate action that is long
overdue
immigration reform is not historically a
democratic or republican priority but an
american one
modernizing it is long overdue the
system we expect elected officials from
both sides of the isles to come to the
table so we can finally
get this done i also wanted to note
numbers out this morning on new
unemployment claims
jobless claims increased and for 48
weeks in a row now new regular
unemployment
claims have outpaced their pre-pendant
high combined with stalled job growth
over the last three months
we have a clear picture of the trouble
our economy is in and the financial pain
being felt by millions of americans
economist
experts and leaders across the political
spectrum have come out in support of the
rescue plan because they know it's the
best tool
we have to get us through this economic
storm create millions of jobs and get
americans back to work
also many of you have been asking for a
preview of the president's
remarks and engagement uh remotely at
the g7 and munich security conference
tomorrow so let me
venture to do that and then we'll take
your questions tomorrow morning
or i will take your questions i should
say tomorrow morning president biden
will join fellow world leaders
at a virtual gathering of the g7 this
will be the first gathering of g7
leaders since april of 2020.
this virtual engagement with leaders of
the world's leading democratic market
economies
will provide an opportunity for
president biden to discuss plans to
defeat the kova 19 pandemic
and rebuild the global economy president
biden will focus on a global response to
the covet pandemic
including coordination on vaccine
production distribution and supplies
as well as continued efforts to mobilize
and cooperate
against the threat of emerging
infectious diseases by building country
capacity and establishing health
security financing
in january on president biden's first
day in office he announced that the
united states would re-engage with the
world health organization to strengthen
global health
his first national security memorandum
was focused on covert 19
and the relationship between a safe and
secure united states
defeating copen19 improving global
global health
and advancing domestic and global health
security to prevent detect and respond
to future biological catastrophes
the administration has pledged the
united states will join the kovats
initiative
to purchase and distribute vaccines
globally and through a multilateral
mechanism
these global efforts reinforce the
president's progress to address the cove
pandemic at home including increasing
the pace of vaccinations
instituting public health measures for
safe travel and providing schools with
scientific guidance for safe operations
president biden will also discuss the
global economic recovery
including the importance of all
industrialized countries maintaining
economic support for the recovery
and collective measures to build back
better as we build that better we must
ensure that the recovery is inclusive
and benefits all workers
including women and members of
historically disadvantaged groups
and all parts of our country he will
also discuss the need to make
investments to strengthen our collective
competitiveness
and the importance of updating global
rules to tackle economic challenges
such as those posed by china finally
president biden
and other leaders will also discuss a
robust agenda of measures
to address the global climate crisis a
key priority for the administration
the february 19th virtual engagement
will be hosted by prime minister boris
johnson
as part of this year's uk's g7
presidency and head of the plan g7
summit
in june of 2021. uh also uh
uh i will i will stop there um with that
i'm happy to open it up and take your
questions and we want to take i want to
take as many as possible so we always
love follow-ups but
we want to get to as many people as
possible as we have an opportunity to do
this virtually today
so art we're ready to open it up as a
reminder if you have a question please
press
one then zero once again if you have a
question or comment one's in zero
zeke miller with associated pressure
open
hi zeke
sorry z press one zero again you might
have took yourself out
one moment
once again zeke if you're still on
please press one zero
and we'll move on we have uh
jennifer jacobs bloomberg news please go
ahead
hi jennifer as we can slightly
but we're trying question
about reports on the recovery package um
being about three trillion dollars for
jobs and infrastructure as part of
the president's buildback better program
is the three trillion dollars about
in the ballpark that you're talking
about
well jennifer let me first say that
right now the administration's sole
priority
our sole priority is getting the
american rescue plan passed
which means getting shots in the arms of
the american people getting families
urgent economic relief they need
ensuring communities have the resources
they need in the fight against
covet i would not expect the president
or any of us
to lay out next pieces of his agenda
until that package is through and signed
and that release is out
going out to the public so there have
been a range of reports
but what i can confirm for you is that
there are discussions that are ongoing
about the president's agenda looking
ahead
no decisions that no final decisions
have been made and we're certainly not
at the point where we are
either finalizing or previewing his
future proposals
one more one
maybe open it up to the next question
one moment we'll search as well
are we are we waiting for somebody to to
ask a question
or are we having a technical issue
jen i think we're having a technical
issue give us a second thank you
okay our next question will come from
the line of
andrea shalala of reuters please go
ahead
hi andrea thank you so much
to ask you a little bit from the
technical infrastructure
but i'm getting an echo
you i can hear you very much a little
bit
in and out a little bit but maybe could
you start your question from the top
yeah i just put on a headset i think
that'll make it easier
okay okay so my question is
what we just heard about these
forthcoming efforts to
shore up the infrastructure grid in
texas do you have any idea
whether that will be included in the
recovery package that you're talking
about would that be a separate measure
do you have any kind of sense of the
price tag of that
and um i just have a separate question
on the kovacs effort
sure there's there is a waiver that has
been
proposed by india and south africa that
would
temporarily suspend intellectual
property protection
to ensure that vaccines can
get through places in developing
countries
is that something that the united states
supports it was blocked by the previous
administration
well let me first say on kovacs that i
expect we'll have more news
on the in the next 24 hours on our
engagement
and contributions to the overall global
effort
but our commitment is to uh work
with and through kovacs to ensure that
uh
we are both uh there is equitable
distribution of vaccines and funding
globally and also that there is a
standard uh
through which these vaccines are
considered and distributed
um i i'm happy to talk to our team about
that specific waiver but again i just
wanted to reiterate that we are planning
uh we are committed to working through
kovacs and we'll have more
our global on our contribution of the
global effort in the next 24 hours i
believe there's also going to be a call
later this afternoon to outline that
in more specific detail uh on your first
question
uh and your first question can you just
say that one more time i apologize
yeah i basically it's best thing about
the need to shore up the
power grid that we're just seeing now in
texas
and whether that is already part of the
recovery what you're thinking about the
recovery sun whether it'll be folded in
and if you have any
estimates of what that specific
component of
coverage infrastructure would entail
well i would first say that again
our sole priority right now is getting
the american rescue plan
passed there are uh this there is still
more work to be done
on that front we are we have our foot on
the gas and we are remaining engaged
with democrats and republicans on the
hill about moving that forward it is not
on the president's desk it is not signed
and it is not
that release is not in the hands of the
american people at the same time
there are ongoing discussions internally
and with stakeholders in consultation
about
uh what the agenda looks like the
president's agenda
looks like moving forward uh but no
final decisions have been made
and so i'm not in a position naturally
to preview that uh but i wouldn't expect
that we will preview anything or you'll
hear the president talk about it until
the american rescue plan
is passed in terms of your question
about
texas as dr sherwood randall conveyed
clearly you know there is a need to
assess
and take a look at how we protect and
uh support critical infrastructure
across the country
including our uh our national energy
grids and ensure that we are
uh better prepared in the future there's
plenty of time to have that conversation
uh right now our focus is on working uh
every lever that we have at our disposal
through the federal government to get
relief to the people of texas so
i don't have anything to preview for you
other than to convey that
our focus is the on the emergency at
hand and that is what we are
uh putting our uh internal and
interagency efforts on
can i just go up president governor
abbott fallen asked him to
try to fix the facts from cause right
i apologize andrew you're kind of coming
in and out can you just start that again
i heard governor abbott but i didn't
hear the rest of the question
okay has the president stopped
uh the president spoke with governor
abbott i believe it was two days ago
and conveyed his commitment to helping
you utilize the the resources available
from the federal government to help the
people of texas
we are engaged at many levels as dr
sherwood randall conveyed
with governors with members of their
teams with fema with local authorities
to ensure that release
is uh is getting to into the right hands
and into the right communities
but i don't have an additional call to
read out for you now
thank you our next question will come
from the line of
nancy cordes of cbs news please go ahead
hi nancy hi jen how are you thank you
for doing this remotely
um my first question is about the um
the immigration bill and i know you
addressed this a little bit yesterday
but what's the white house take on the
pros
and cons of passing parts of the
immigration plan instead of doing it
in one fell swoop a number of these
congressional democrats seem to be very
open to the possibility of doing it in a
piecemeal fashion
sure well first the bill being
introduced
today is represents much of president
biden's vision
which includes addressing some key
components of
what he feels needs to be modernized in
our system including providing an earned
path to citizenship
which includes of course dreamers
responsibly and effectively managing our
borders investing in smart security
and addressing the root causes of
migration from central america
he feels these are each of these
components are vital uh and imperative
uh to address our outdated uh
uh immigration system now he also having
served in
in the senate for 36 years is uh no
stranger to the process of a bill
becoming a law
and he is looking forward to working
directly with members um
hopefully both parties if immigration is
not his immigration reform i should say
has not historically been a democratic
or republican issue
to determine what the password looks
like and he is
uh all too familiar or very familiar
with the fact that
uh if a bill proposed does typically not
look like the final bill
signs but it is just being formally
proposed today
we are eager to work with democrats
republicans members of the chc others
who have been working
passionately on these issues for a long
period of time uh and at this point
um you know he's just looking forward to
having bill uh to sign at his death
thanks and then um what is the white
house take on
this concern that has been voiced by
some house democrats like henrique or
vicente gonzalez that if you
put out something this ambitious this
early that it's
first going to motivate a surge of
migrants to try to come here
and also open up president biden to
attempts by republicans to try to paint
him as
soft on immigration
well um you know i would say on the uh
the fact that the president put forward
uh felt it was a priority
to put forward an immigration bill on
his first day in office
just reflects his own commitment to
modernizing an outdated system and also
taking every step he can
to move forward from the chaos cruelty
and confusion
that was created by the immigration
policies of the last four years
uh that's not uh that's that's not a
position
or an approach that's being done through
a political prism but through
a moral prison what is right for the
country what is right for the millions
of immigrants
who are living in the shadows and
frankly what is right for
uh our security at the border uh and
what is right for addressing the root
causes that uh that led to
the crises at the border that that we
have seen
over the course of the last several
years at the same time as we have done
many times
we will continue to convey and repeat
from from
level the need the fact that this is not
the right time to come
uh we have not we don't have the systems
in place we don't have the policies in
place we don't have the laws in place or
the processing in place
at the border uh to uh consider a
wave of uh of people fleeing their
countries um we
we are uh this is a priority we're eager
to get it through and we're also going
to take additional steps
as you've seen from the department of
homeland security uh and their efforts
uh
to increase processing uh through
executive actions
uh to uh inject some morality into this
uh system but it this is not that the
time to come uh we are eager to move
forward this uh with this as quickly as
possible and him
proposing it on the first day moving it
forward within a month is a reflection
of that priority
thanks jen thank you nancy
our next question will come from the
line of franchesca chambers of mcclatchy
please go ahead
hi friends i can
okay great thank you thanks jen for
doing this
so uh two questions related to the
disaster relief aid and then
something on another topic i guess that
can take them separately to make this
easier
is there federal assistance or aid
available to municipalities
who previously paid or paying high gas
prices for natural gas
or does that assistance depend on a
state request
for instance the state of missouri would
they have to make that request for a
municipality
and then on a related topic uh uh alicia
with randall had mentioned a request
from louisiana
for disaster relief aid but what about
the other states that have been affected
and whose governors the president spoke
with earlier this week such as kansas or
kentucky
have they requested aid and if so when
could they expect to get that
sure well francesca i would say
typically how it works is that
um states requests or in coordination of
course a declaration of an emergency
uh you know a disaster declaration and
we work closely with them at the federal
level to do exactly that
uh we have been sharing with all of you
our engagements on a daily basis so you
all are kept abreast of those
conversations um but i would certainly
point you to
some of the state governments on what
their needs are and requests
um uh and what they've been requesting
specifically of the federal government
to ensure it's helping uh provide the
assistance to the people in their states
that's needed during this difficult time
of the storm it's an excellent question
about municipalities i will have to
follow up with our
our homeland security team on that
specific technical question a good one
but
we'll maybe we can connect you with them
directly after the briefing
okay and then on another topic the vice
president
said today that she views the number of
women leaving the workforce as a
national emergency
does the president share the vice
president's view on that
and if so does he plan to make a
national emergency
declaration and take action to address
the declining number of women in the
workforce
aside from the stimulus package that
he's presented to congress
well francesca i would first say that
this is something the president and vice
president have discussed
um and he has raised with with uh in a
number of meetings i have been in with
him
his concern about the impact of the dual
crises of covid19 and the economic
downturn on women in the workforce
as you as you well know it is not just
about women who are leaving the
workforce now it is about what the
impact will be
in future years if there are women
taking themselves
out of the running for moving up the
corporate ladder out of the running for
seeking phds for getting law degrees uh
you know women taking themselves
off of the front lines of essential
industries like health care work that
has an impact of course on
gender equality it also has an impact on
the economy
moving forward and any economist will
convey that to you so the president has
conveyed
in many meetings i've been in his
concern about this directly and i know
he's discussed it with the vice
president as well
i would say the american rescue plan the
key components in there
uh some are meant to help address uh
exactly this crisis
um including funding to reopen schools
as a mom myself i can confirm for you
and many mothers across the country can
confirm for you that
the fact that schools still need
additional resources to reopen obviously
the cdc guidelines give us a good guide
post give school districts a good
guide plus but many still need funding
that having kids go back to school has
an impasse on many working mothers of
course
also ensuring direct relief goes out
through checks
that's something who will help that will
help households whether they are single
parent households or dual income
households where one of the individuals
is laid off
10 million americans have been laid off
so there's no question many of them as
we know statistically
are certainly women and certainly
getting people vaccinated
will help more people return to the
workforce more more kids go to child
care centers
and again schools as i said so i would
say president recognizes
uh the severity of this crisis the
impact on women
that's uh part of the reason why he why
there are some of these key components
in this package and
uh he certainly agrees with the vice
president's assessment
he agrees that it's a national emergency
do you agree certainly that
it's a an emergency and a crisis
francesca but i think we're gonna have
to move on because i want to take a few
more questions
and we'll certainly connect you with uh
on the municipalities question
thanks john our next question will come
from the line of jeremy diamond of cnn
please go ahead
thank you jeremy hey jen thanks for
doing this
um so on the immigration bill um
you know obviously fern burner for you
guys right now is the coronavirus relief
legislation
so i'm curious if you could explain on
the decision to introduce this today
um you know why now while there's
clearly
a higher priority for you guys as it
relates to congress
and then secondly um you know there
isn't much in the way of new funding for
border security and enforcement in this
bill
i'm wondering if the president is open
to increasing uh funding
for border security including for more
wall or fencing construction
in order to get this bill through
uh well first let me say uh that the
president introduced
uh or i should say uh announced his
plans to introduce this package to work
with congress to introduce this package
on his first day in office because
she believes that modernizing our
immigration system is
an absolute priority for the country and
that we are able to
members of congress are able to move
forward in
negotiating uh the components of the
package
and what it will look like in a final
package even while we are pushing
forward
on uh on our uh our effort to get the
american rescue plan passed
and as you all know jeremy and many
people on the phone know
um there there is uh there are
negotiations that will need to happen
this is there
there was a reset that was really needed
to get uh
immigration bill uh discussed and uh
and negotiated and and that is what our
effort is to do here
uh as you know representative sanchez
senator menendez
are starting this process and we
certainly are eager to have many more
co-sponsors
republicans join that given that this
has historically been an issue democrats
and republicans are committed to
there is uh of course funding in here
one of the key components of the bill
is investing in smart security up at our
ports of entry and doing in a way that's
actually effective
uh the the funding the entire strategy
of the last four years
was to um to uh to do funding for a wall
that
was not effective in um in securing our
border was not effective in
providing a pathway to citizenship
obviously was not effective
at addressing the root causes that is
not our strategy
but there will be a discussion and
negotiation we certainly understand that
the
sausages that comes out of the machine
on the other side will look different
from the sausage that's introduced today
we're supportive of that and we'll look
forward to working with congress to get
the bill uh
moving forward and just real quickly on
another topic um
florida governor ron desantis yesterday
threatened to move a pop-up vaccination
clinic after facing
criticism from some county officials he
threatened to move it to another county
would that kind of action by governor
desantis or any other governor affect
federal government shipments of vaccines
to florida and prompt the federal
government to
take oversight of vaccination deliveries
and administration in a state
well first let me say that uh our effort
to
vaccinate get 100 million vaccines in
the arms of american 100 million shots
in the arms of americans i should say in
the first hundred days and exceed that
goal
is uh not through a political prism and
we certainly
would not support any effort to um
to uh you know have the people of
florida or any state
democrat or republican blue or red
impacted by
the decisions of their leadership uh so
no i would not see us
taking action in those in that along
those lines
we have increased as you know jeremy the
shipment to states
by 57 since the president took office
there are a number of ways that vaccines
are being distributed in
in florida but of course in states
across the country um
but uh you know we remain committed to
doing that and
i i don't have anything more on that
specific report which i had not had the
chance to review before the briefing
our next question will come from the
line of nikki schwab
of daily mail please go ahead hi jen can
you hear me
i can great um just wondering if the
president has any reaction to these
reports that say senator ted cruz who
the cancun
ended this giant winter storm in his
home state of texas
well i don't have any updates on the
exact location of senator ted cruz
nor does anyone at the white house but
our focus
is on uh and working directly with
leadership in texas and the surrounding
states
on addressing the winter storm and the
crisis at hand
the many people across the state who are
without power
without the resources they need and we
expect
that would be the focus of anyone in the
state or surrounding states
who was elected to represent them but i
don't have any update on his
whereabouts
our next question will come from the
line of joey garrison of usa today
please go ahead
yeah jen uh thanks for taking this call
uh can you hear me sure
i can hey how are you uh republicans
increasingly
are jumping on the uh reopening
schools issue uh for the 22
midterm elections trying to blame
democrats and joe biden for the reason
uh you know as parents children aren't
in school
what's your reaction to that what's uh
pretty openly a line of attack right now
and do you think that's a fair
line of attack right now you know as
you're looking ahead
towards the midterms well let me
first say on the political front that no
polling i have seen has shown that as
effective
um and there was actually a poll out
yesterday that showed that
president biden um and teachers were
the most trusted uh entities in terms of
determining when school should reopen we
obviously
uh rely on science and rely on our
health experts
and we think that reflects uh where most
of the country want us to be they want
schools to reopen we're also committed
to doing that so there are cdc
guidelines that came out
on friday that provided a
roadmap for schools to open uh
safely the president wants schools to
open uh
five days a week he wants kids to be in
school teachers want kids to be in
school
and he also believes that teachers
should be prioritized as do
as does the vice president so but he
also believes
that there are a range of mitigation
steps or i should say he follows the
guidelines as we all
do and should that were put out by our
health and medical experts
that show there are a range of
mitigation steps vaccinations are one of
the additional steps that the cdc is
recommending
but there are additional steps including
masking smaller class sizes
and he is eager to have his secretary of
education confirmed
so that he can work with school
districts across the country
lead that effort to to
reopen schools and we remain committed
to that
any concern about this issue though
making democrats vulnerable
in 2022 if it's not turned around if
schools don't start rebuilding
here in the coming months well i would
say that the president the vice
president
and this white house don't see reopening
schools
through a political prism we see it as
what's in the interest of teachers of
students of families of parents and we
want to do it safely
and the president is committed to
reopening schools
five days a week as quickly as possible
he is committed to also following
science
and working with school districts to
having his secretary of education work
with school districts
to get that done uh and he is also what
is it within his power
is that we we are working with congress
to get
additional funding which is essential to
many school districts across the country
so that they can follow and take these
mitigation steps recommended by the cdc
including interest masking smaller class
sizes uh that
there are more bus drivers hired that
there are more teachers hired if needed
uh that's within the president's power
something he's focused on every day and
night
so that we can open schools open them
five days a week
uh within 100 days and
that's where focus is we don't see that
through a political prison kids are not
democrats or republicans
and their parents i think this is an
issue that all americans care deeply
about
thanksgiving
our next question will come from the
line of
kayla tausch of cnbc please go ahead
hi kayla hi jen thank you for doing this
we appreciate it
i have two questions one domestic one
foreign the first
is on the economy this week we saw
retail sales and inflation data
that were unexpectedly strong i'm
wondering how the white house is
factoring that data into the size of the
rescue package
and whether 1.9 trillion dollars would
as some critics say
overheat the economy and then my foreign
question
which i'll just go ahead and ask is that
iran has said it will stop allowing snap
inspections
by the iaea beginning on monday if
parties to the nuclear deal don't take
their own steps toward full compliance
does the president see this as
motivation to engage with iran sooner
rather than later
well uh let me take the second question
first
if that makes sense um iran is a long
way from compliance
our focus is on working with our
partners and allies to
to engage and coordinate on a range of
issues including
the future of the iran nuclear deal uh
secretary
blinken has a meeting with his e3
counterparts
later this afternoon and i would expect
the state department would have a
readout from that meeting but certainly
uh our uh our focus is of course on
preventing iran from acquiring a nuclear
reveal
but they are a long way from compliance
and our on our focus is also on working
with our partners and allies
on uh uh our priority i should say kayla
on on the
uh economic question i know a number of
our economic experts including uh
uh secretary uh our secretary of
treasury have answered this question
but i will say that um most economists
will tell
you and most economic data will show
that
we are crawling out of a massive hole
and it's we're crawling out too slowly
and that uh what is essential is to
ensure that we have um
uh we put in uh you know
of course stimulus into our economy uh
to help
uh expedite that and that is part of
what this package will do
by providing direct relief to the
american people by reopening schools
which will have a huge impact on
working mothers and parents across the
country by getting vaccinations in the
arms of the american people
most economic data and studies have
shown that
this package will have a significant
impact on that
and that we still have a long way to go
in our recovery so it is essential at
this point in time
thank you appreciate it sure our next
question will come from the line of
peter alexander of
nbc news please go ahead hi jeff thanks
thanks for hosting us sorry we can't do
it in person you sort of hit on this a
bit but i just want to
sort of drill down a little bit on the
immigration announcement
today and what specifically is the
strategy for this white house to get
this
immigration bill passed right now will
you bring republicans here to engage
them in the process would you do it
through reconciliation
how are you going to get something this
big done sure
all great questions peter i think we're
not quite there uh
because today is the day that the bill
is being proposed uh
obviously senator menendez uh
congresswoman sanchez will be
key leaders uh on the hill to uh
determine
in coordination with us the next steps
forward
but right now uh we are eager to
communicate about what is in the package
why the key components why all of the
components are pivotal pieces of the
package
and in terms of the mechanisms or the
the
um timeline or the mechanics uh you know
we're we're happy to have that
conversation in the weeks ahead but
today
uh we're just it's the bill is just
being officially introduced
thank you our next question
i'm just going to take two more
questions and we'll of course do this
again tomorrow but i just have a
bit of a heart out coming up but go
ahead whoever's next
our next question will come from the
line of matt visser of the washington
post please go ahead
uh hey jim thanks for doing this in an
unusual circumstance um we we know
from earlier that biden spoke with
governors on tuesday
about the weather conditions
um most of his visibility though has
been on
another disaster of covid um can you
highlight a little bit
just how hands-on biden himself
has been with the with the natural
disasters if he's briefed
hourly daily if he has any plans to
visit
any of these states or plans to say
anything
more broadly about it at this time
sure i will say that the president is
kept
abreast of the developments um in texas
and the surrounding states
and receives updates uh every day but
more more than more than once a day
um it is uh certainly a focus um and as
uh and uh ensuring that the people of
texas the people of the surrounding
states have the
resources they need is something that he
raped us
um in in meetings uh frequently and has
over the past couple of days
in terms of whether he will visit you
know i think as you well know matt
one of the factors to consider here is
what the impact is the footprint
right of a presidential trip uh it can
take up resources it can take up
um you know the time and energy of
police and security and so those are
factors that we consider as we determine
when and where he will visit
but he is does receive he is in the
white house today of course that's where
he lives but he is
i should say um you know working today
receiving updates today
i expect he would receive uh several
updates from his national security team
and he is focused on and has directed
his team
to provide him uh ensure he's updated
but also make
rapid decisions and be responsive to the
specific needs of the states as they
come up during this difficult time
thank you okay i'll take uh one more
question and we'll
we'll do this again tomorrow well
different version of this but
our next question and q will come from
the line
of mr james rosen of sinclair broadcast
group
please go ahead thank you jen can hear
me all right
i can hi jane jen thanks for expanding
the call today and it's nice to be back
with you if only by telephone
uh i just wanted to
follow up on the comments of liz to have
the deputy national security adviser
brief us
on the texas grid collapse
you know it's not just the immediate
logistical issues that she's grappling
with
i want to ask about the nexus between
energy policy and national security
as you know republicans in congress and
in the energy sector
have been pointing out that uh according
to data
from the u.s energy information
administration the u.s achieved
uh one of the core benchmarks of energy
independence in 2019
that was the first year since 1957 that
the u.s produced more energy than the
country
consumed and that's one basic definition
of energy independence and
they claim or they argue that the
policies being pursued by the bible
administration will sacrifice those
gains how do you persuade the american
people that u.s
national security can be safeguarded by
this transition to a green economy
which of course has never been fully
developed anywhere relative to to our
scale
well james you know in this white house
we like to
follow the facts and also rely on
experts
as you know and i would say that um
you know officials at the electric
reliability council of texas which
operates the state's power grid
has said that the failures in winds and
solar were the least significant factor
in the blackouts
and there have been a range of reports
that have suggested otherwise
inaccurately but that's not accurate
according to the electoral
liability council of texas as dr
sherwood
randall also conveyed um clearly um
there is a need to assess
uh how we uh protect and and and
support our national infrastructure uh
to ensure it's resilient
uh and sustainable during
storms during any threats to it
and there is of course plenty of time to
do that and it is a priority for this
administration but right now
our focus for focus the president's
focus is on
ensuring that the millions of people or
the many many people across these states
the states that are impacted
are receiving the relief and assistance
they need uh so we will have those
policy discussions
uh but we are focused on the emergency
at hand at this point in time
thank you everybody so much for joining
uh the briefing really appreciate your
flexibility and
getting through the technical details
and i'll look forward to talking with
all of you tomorrow